multiply and express as a simplified
rational state the domain so let's
multiply it and then before we simplify
it let's look at the domain so this is
equal to if we just multiply the
numerators a squared minus 4 times a
plus 1 a plus 1 all of that over
multiply the denominators a squared
minus 1 times a plus 2 a plus 2 now the
a squared minus 4 and the a squared
minus 1 might look familiar to us these
are the difference in squares a special
type of binomial that you can
immediately or hopefully maybe
immediately recognize take the form a
squared minus B squared difference of
squares and it's always going to be
equal to a plus B times a minus B so we
can factor this a squared minus 4 and we
can also factor this a squared minus 1
and that'll help us actually simplify
the expression or the simplify the
rational so this top part we can break
up the we can factor the a squared minus
4 as a plus 2 right 2 squared is 4 times
a minus 2 and then that times a plus 1
times a plus 1 and then in the
denominator we can factor a squared
minus 1 factor a squared minus 1 let me
do that in a different color a squared
minus 1 we can factor as a plus 1 times
a minus 1 and if you ever want to say
hey why does this work just multiply it
out and you'll see that when you
multiply these two things you get that
thing right there then the denominator
we also have an A plus 2 we also have an
A plus 2 so we factored the new we've
multiplied it we factored out the
numerator we factored out the
denominator let's rearrange it a little
bit so this numerator let's put the A
plus 2's first in both the numerator and
the denominator so this we could get a
plus 2 in the numerator and then in the
denominator we also have an A plus 2 in
the numerator so we took care of our a
plus twos we have let's see we have well
that's the only one that's common so in
the numerator we
an a-minus to actually have an a-plus
one let's write that there do a plus one
we have an A plus 1 in the numerator we
also have an A plus 1 in the denominator
a plus 1 in the denominator and the
numerator we have an a minus 2 a minus 2
and the denominator we have an a minus 1
a minus 1 so all I did is I rearranged
the numerator in the denominator so if
there was something that it was of a
similar it was the same expression was
in both I just wrote them on top of each
other essentially now before we simplify
this is a good time to think about the
domain or think about the a values that
aren't in the domain the a values that
would invalidate or make this expression
undefined so like we've seen before the
a values that would do that are the ones
that would make the denominator equal
zero so the a values that would make
that equal to zero is a is equal to
negative two I mean you could solve for
you could say a plus two is equal to
zero or a is equal to negative two a
plus one is equal to zero subtract one
from both sides a is equal to negative 1
or a minus one is equal to zero let's
add 1 to both sides and you get a is
equal to one so this expression for this
expression right here you have to add
the constraint that a cannot equal a
cannot equal negative two negative one
or one that a can be any real number
except for these this is this is we're
essentially stating our domain we're
saying it can be the domain is all
possible A's except for these things
right here so we'd have to add that
little cut that little caveat right
there now now that we've done that we
can factor it so we have an A plus two
over na plus two we know that a is not
going to be equal to negative two so
that's always going to be defined and so
when you divide something by itself that
is going to just be one same thing where
the eight plus one over the a plus one
that's going to be one and all you're
going to be left with is an a minus two
over a minus one so the simplified
rational is a minus two over a minus one
with the constraint with the constraint
that a cannot equal negative two
negative one or one now you're probably
saying hey Sal what's wrong with it
equally so for example negative one here
negative one minus one it's only going
to be a negative two here it's going to
be defined but
for this expression in order for that
expression to really be the same as this
expression up here it has to have the
same constraints it has to have the same
domain it cannot be defined at negative
one if this guy also is not defined at
negative one and so this one these
constraints essentially ensure that
we're dealing with the same expression
not one that's just close